Reggie, où te vois-tu dans cinq
ans,
je veux tout le West End, je veux mon
nom et j'allume de
grandes affiches de film avec moi dessus, c'est un
vrai travail, je
m'inquiète, tu es un idiot qui
va s'enfuir avec mon argent,
[ __ ] de m'avoir  et vous pourriez être plus
assertif qu'en pensez-vous
oui monsieur j'ai dit que vous pourriez être plus
oui monsieur qui êtes-vous quel est votre nom c'est
ma propriété qu'est-
ce que vous avez fait
ici nous sommes le palais rose
il y a beaucoup de garçons qui '  Je vais rentrer à la maison
ces jours-ci, il y en a de plus en plus chaque
mois
et je ne pense pas que nous les reverrons un jour, n'est-ce pas,
mais le rhume est revenu et l'a emmené à
l'hôpital. Il a dit que c'était étrange, il a dit que c'était
une sorte de psychose,
qu'est-ce que tu es ?  avoir des pirates tu n'as pas
de pouvoir bien sûr nous n'avons pas de
[ __ ] de perroquet
Richard Toeser
[Musique]
tu sens le propre viens t'asseoir devant moi
sors de chez moi mais je suis très doué
avec les langues
[Musique]
j'ai  Je n'ai pas eu plus de douche rapide ouais
ensemble ouais
as-tu vu ça
toi